India's attempt to make one giant leap
end it at the final step of its unmanned
mission to the moon
the vikram lunar lander lost contact
with controllers in india just two
kilometers above the moon's surface the
disappointment of the mission
controllers in Bengaluru was obvious
scientists working for India Space
Research Organisation will have to wait
longer in their search for water on the
moon millions all over India were glued
to TV screens waiting for the Indian
flag to be unfurled at the South Pole of
the moon no one has ever explored there
I think it's a stepping stone you can't
expect a very new experiment and mission
to always be perfect right but we've
learned so much from it and we can
analyse what went wrong and make sure it
doesn't happen again the 20-day
chandrayaan-2 mission cost 140 million
dollars despite the failure to - the
hopes of the nation further missions are
already planned the Indian Prime
Minister's words were reassuring good to
talk about the high we will look back at
this journey an effort with great
satisfaction the learning from today
will make us stronger and better there
will be a new dawn and a brighter
tomorrow very soon
India's mission to the moon may have
failed in the final moments but while
the lunar lander has been lost
officials expect to receive crucial
images from the orbiter and even though
there is disappointment just now the
government says there will be a next
time after the US the Soviet Union and
China India would have been only the
fourth nation to successfully land on
the moon had its mission ended in
success rather than disappointment
algebra al jazeera New Delhi